y comenzamos nuestra sección directo a
donde Vamos hasta antigua en Guatemala
allí estaba nuestro corresponsales
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo Y
es que hoy 30 de noviembre Guatemala
conmemoró el día del periodista una
fecha que celebra desde hace exactamente
50 años pues se comenzó en 1972 sin
embargo el país ha empeorado en sus
niveles de libertad de expresión según
la sociedad Interamericana de prensa
conectemos entonces con antigua Andrés
buenas noches y un placer hablar con
usted ahora para contextualizar esta
fecha cuéntenos Cuál es el panorama de
la libertad de expresión en Guatemala
Buenas noches María Clara El gusto es
recíproco bueno el panorama de la
libertad de expresión en este país
centroamericano es preocupante sobre
todo cobró relevancia en los últimos
meses porque los propios periodistas
locales han denunciado hostigamiento del
Ministerio Público han denunciado el
hecho de agresiones físicas de parte de
la policía persecución política en su
labor de denunciar de destapar los
diferentes escándalos de corrupción con
que se relacionan a al actual mandatario
el presidente Alejandro yamatey de esta
manera la Comisión Interamericana de los
Derechos Humanos el pasado mes de
octubre realizó un simple un simposio
con la red rompe el miedo en Guatemala
en la que se denunció que más de 60
periodistas han sido agredidos
físicamente seis de ellos han tenido que
ser exiliados del país y el caso más
sonado del de José Rubén Zamora que se
encuentra encarcelado porque ha sido un
fuerte crítico de yamatey de esta manera
la cidh le recuerda al estado guatemal
dijo que garantice el derecho de
libertad de expresión y las cif la
sociedad Interamericana de prensa
anunció una investigación el próximo mes
de diciembre para estas violaciones a la
libertad de prensa y usted precisamente
mencionó a José Rubén Zamora que era el
presidente del medio llamado el
periódico Él lleva cuatro meses
encarcelado y hoy justamente en el día
del periodista se anunció la cancelación
de la edición impresa de el periódico
cuéntenos un poco qué está pasando con
este medio y cuál es el caso de Zamora
fíjense que Guatemala es todavía un país
donde la prensa impresa el periódico en
físico es muy apetecido y el plan que
tenía el periódico de convertirse en un
medio digital estaba planeado solo para
el 2025 de manera que hoy se han quedado
sin trabajo 170 personas en el día del
periodista no hay nada que celebrar para
este medio de comunicación las razones
son sobre todo que la captura del
fundador del director de este medio José
Rubén Zamora por haber destapado
numerosos escándalos de corrupción que
relacionan al presidente Alejandro
ayamate y entre ellos la compra
multimillonaria de vacunas sputnik que a
la postre se vencieron pero sobre todo
fue una publicación que relacionó a
yamatei en una relación extramarital con
un ex funcionario del gobierno lo que
detonó la captura y de esta manera
también el congelamiento de las cuentas
por parte del gobierno de este medio
impreso así las cosas el periódico se
queda sin su versión impresa y a las
personas a que con cada suscripción es
un grito en contra de la impunidad y la
corrupción en Guatemala bueno una mala
noticia en el día del periodista Gracias
Andrés por este